James Cameron has been promising a
series of Avatar sequels for roughly a
decade and audiences are still waiting
and so now you're worried about the
sequels that are coming out we've
already heard quite a few tidbits about
what the upcoming films will entail and
we've rounded up all the rumors and
spoilers right here James Cameron
clearly wasn't interested in churning
out another avatar sequel just for the
sake of it since 2010 he's been dropping
hints about what the future of the
franchise involves and it's an
increasingly ungainly vision that
includes several movie sequels novels
and much more details are often
frustratingly vague BEC even the release
dates keep changing in fact trying to
pin down exactly when we'll get to see
avatar 2 and its mini sequels
is something of a fool's errand back in
2010 Cameron said the next two films
would be coming out in December 2014 in
December 2015 respectively but when
January 2015 rolled around with no sign
of avatar 2 he said the sequels had been
delayed but they'd be coming out in 2017
probably later in 2015 Cameron also
hinted that there'd be an avatar 5 in
April 2016 James Cameron told folks at
Comic Con the next time I see you will
be on Pandora he also claimed that
Christmas time would officially be
avatar time because avatar 2 would be
coming out on Christmas 2018 of course
that didn't happen then in April 2017
the timeline shifted again and Cameron
announced we could expect avatar 2 on
December 18th 2020 is your head spinning
yet December 18 2020 was the official
word for another two years but that all
changed on May 2019 after Disney
acquired Fox the studio that had
previously owned avatar it was announced
that four forthcoming Avatar films
expanding the vibrant world of Pandora
will release on the pre Christmas
weekend every other year beginning in
2021 that's the story for now anyway
I'm sorry two three four yeah yeah
seriously so either they're all written
and we've done the capture we still
don't know for sure what the official
title of avatar two will be at one point
James Cameron reportedly didn't even
want the word avatar in future
installments of the series in 2012 he
pointed out that Jake left his avatar to
become a real Navi at the end of Avatar
is whatever happens to it a the William
nothing - coming back to this place
because of this major plot development
Cameron claimed the term avatar no
longer applies to the series but perhaps
he's had a change of heart or perhaps he
was strong-armed by Studio brass into
keeping the word avatar in the film
titles in 2018 the BBC claimed they'd
seen documents that referred to for
upcoming avatar projects that were
called avatar the way of water avatar
the seed bearer avatar the Tolkien
writer and last but certainly not least
avatar the quest for a walk of course as
with all things avatar all these titles
should be taken with an unusually large
grain of salt James Cameron has said
that most of what we'll see on-screen in
the for avatar sequels is motion capture
footage his team reportedly started
filming back in September 2017 working
on avatar 2 and avatar 3 back to back as
well as scenes for the fourth
installment at an IMAX Q&A in February
2009 teen producer John Landau revealed
we're going to do our live-action
filming in New Zealand in the spring of
this year then in an interview with
Empire that same month James Cameron
revealed that pesky little live-action
component is going to cost me 5 months
of my life across the two movies we
expect to see Sam Worthington and Zoe
Saldana return for the Avatar sequels
but we were quite surprised to hear that
Sigourney Weaver and Stephen Lang are
reportedly returning for all four films
- after all both characters were
supposedly killed off in the first film
dr. grace Augustine was struck by a
fatal bullet and Colonel Quaritch was
hit by two arrows fired by Saldana's
character Neytiri weaver claims she'll
be playing a different character in the
upcoming movies but James Cameron
confirmed that Lang will somehow be
returning as the
willd colonel in fact he'll supposedly
be the primary villain in future films
which isn't to say he was a sweetheart
in the original avatar you crossed a
line it was revealed that oscar-winning
actress Kate Winslet had been cast as a
character named Rowan all talking to
Vanity Fair in 2017 Cameron said she's
very excited she plays a character who's
part of the C people the reef people
the one thing she did do is demand that
she do all her own water work the fact
that Cameron and Winslet are working
together again may raise a few eyebrows
after all their experience filming
Titanic didn't exactly sound like smooth
sailing no pun intended
reportedly Winslet was often afraid that
she'd drowned while filming Titanic and
she once said of Cameron there were
times when I was genuinely frightened of
him jim has a temper like you wouldn't
believe but producer John Landau claims
Winslet took to her watery scenes in the
Avatar sequels like well like a duck
takes to water heat old collider Kate
Winslet had to train in this and she got
up to a static breath hold of just about
seven minutes it's amazing it's mind
over matter you see Kate going
underwater and she just felt so
comfortable that's no small feat in 2017
it was announced that Game of Thrones
actress Oona Chaplin would be playing a
character named for rank
deadline reported that farang is a
strong and vibrant central character who
spans the entire saga of the sequels in
March 2019 the official avatar Twitter
account posted the Chaplin would be
joined by a fellow former Game of
Thrones cast member run away little
Fiona it's what you do best
the tweet reads Brendan Cowell has been
cast in the Avatar sequels as mix
Scoresby captain of a large scale marine
hunting vessel on pandora and here's
more great news for you on February 6
2019 an announcement on the avatar
Twitter account revealed we are thrilled
to share that Edie Falco is joining the
avatar family as general Ardmore the
commander in charge of the RDAs
interests in the Avatar sequels are you
as excited as we are during an IMAX Q&A
in February 2009
producer John Landau praised that
particular casting choice in typical Jim
Cameron fashion he finds this powerful
woman to play what could be very easily
a male role if people were just to read
the script two months later it was
announced that Michelle Yeoh of crazy
rich Asians would play a scientist named
dr. Corrina mode James Cameron tweeted
Michele has always created unique and
memorable characters I look forward to
working with her to do the same thing on
the Avatar sequels avatars official
Twitter feed isn't the only social media
account buzzing with exciting casting
news on April 3rd 2019 Fast & Furious
star Vin Diesel posted a video to his
Instagram account there is one person in
Hollywood have always wanted to work
with them learn from of course that
strongly implied Diesel would be
appearing in at least one of the avatar
sequels the actor later confirmed his
involvement while speaking to
Entertainment Tonight at the Avengers in
game premiere in April 2009 teen by the
sound of it he's super excited to be
reunited with a certain co-star my
favorite in the whole cast are the
closest of my family is Zoe Saldana
hence avatar has a wandering avatar at
the moment Diesel's IMDB page only lists
his upcoming role in Avatar 2 as rumored
if he is in the film you might have to
be especially eagle-eyed to spot him
motion capture is tricky like that
speaking to Empire James Cameron
revealed that a large chunk of avatar 2
will focus on Jake and a series
eight-year-old daughter he also revealed
that Jake and Metiria are still a couple
and a crucial plot point involves a huge
disagreement between the two lovebirds
[Music]
and you may choose a woman we have many
fine women in fact the audience is
apparently going to watch this fight
play out through the eyes of their
daughter it sounds like there will be
lots of child actors in the Avatar
sequels in 2017 we were introduced to
seven kids who will be playing various
Navi either from the Ares omaticaya clan
or the met ke Gina a community of ocean
dwellers who evidently live on reefs as
Cameron explained he now sees the Avatar
films as a family saga one that's akin
to the Godfather movies he says that
introducing kids into the action
signifies a major shift in perspective
for the adult characters because now
they have to consider how their actions
will affect their families as he tells
it avatar 2 is a continuation of the
same characters but what happens when
warriors who are willing to go on
suicide charges and leap off cliffs what
happens when they grow up and have their
own kids it becomes a very different
story at least two stars will be on
their home turf while shooting the
live-action scenes for the new avatar
films we're talking about New Zealand
here not Andorra outside of his home
country cliff Curtis is best known for
playing Travis in the AMC spinoff series
fear the walking dead he'll be playing
the character of tone owari the leader
of the met que Gina Curtis told Newstalk
zeebee that he didn't even have to
audition I got a phone call from James
Cameron that turned into a Skype call
and he offered me four movies it was
that simple it was a straight invitation
there's one more New Zealand er heading
off to Pandora actor writer and director
Jemaine Clement
you may recognize him as one half of the
comedy duo Flight of the Conchords or
perhaps you've seen his work on the 2014
vampire comedy what we do in the shadows
Clement is also an executive producer on
the FX series of the same name which is
loosely based on the film of course the
hottest thing about making sure like
this is not being bitten by vampires on
May 15th the official avatar Twitter
account announced Jemaine Clement has
been cast in the avatar sequels as dr.
Garvin a marine biologist on pandora
glad to have you aboard
in 2010 Jon Landau told MTV that James
Cameron was planning to write a novel
that offers more insight into the
various characters backgrounds
specifically he said that we'd be
hearing a lot about dr. Augustine's time
teaching in the schoolhouse
this was our school now it's just
storage
we'd also learn more details about
Jake's identical twin brother Tommy
Shirley pretty weak guy with a knife
tickle Tommy would ever be landau noted
that it wouldn't be a novelization of
the first movie but a separate story
that goes into far more detailed in the
first film
Cameron confirmed this saying that he'd
always intended to write a novel if
avatar ever made any money which it most
certainly did but as plans for the
follow-up film stalled plans for the
book evidently stalled - then in 2017
the Los Angeles Times reported that
penguin Random House was teaming up with
Cameron to release a whole slew of books
based on Avatar stories that would be
geared towards children and adults alike
the first books are expected to come out
just before the Avatar - premiere which
means we still have to wait a while
before we can read them if you enjoyed
the colorful visuals of Pandora you'll
be pleased to know that the next four
films are all going to be set there - in
an IMAX queue a producer Jon Landau said
we realized that if we looked at earth
we could spend our whole life traveling
the globe let's do that on Pandora let
Pandora really truly be that metaphor
where we get to go see all these
incredible different environments
meanwhile a lot of the action in Avatar
2 takes place underwater which
reportedly led to a number of production
hitches in November 2017 cameron noted
that basically whenever you add water to
any problem it just gets ten times
harder with any luck we'll be able to
enjoy these avatar sequels before our
entire planet is underwater check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]